Trascrizione: Federica Colombo
Revisore: marshall8 mathers88
Sono sicura che molti di voi
siano appassionati di storie.
Magari c'è a chi piacciono di più i film,
chi le serie tv, chi i libri o i fumetti.
Ma in ogni caso,
il mondo della finzione può dirci
molto più di quanto possiate aspettarvi
sul mondo reale
e può anche ispirarci a migliorare.
È per questo motivo che tra voi
appassionati di storie ci sono anch'io.
Una cosa che ho sempre amato fare
è guardare alla caratterizzazione
dei personaggi delle storie
e soprattutto amo ispirarmi a loro
e rispecchiarmi in loro.
Infatti ho notato,
soprattutto quando siamo bambini,
i nostri personaggi preferiti
possono dirci molto su noi stessi
e possono essere dei veri e propri modelli
che ci possono ispirare.
a voi è mai capitato di vedere un
personaggio sul grande o piccolo schermo
e pensare: “Wow, è proprio come me”?
Beh, è una cosa che ci capita spesso.
Perché a noi piace sentirci rappresentati.
Ci piace vedere qualcuno che condivide
la nostra stessa personalità,
pregi, difetti
ed esperienze.
Bello, vero?
A pensarci bene però,
noto spesso che i personaggi
in cui mi rivedo
non condividono il mio stesso genere
e questo mi ha portata a chiedermi
quante protagoniste donne ci fossero
in tutte le storie che ho seguito,
prendendo in considerazione solo i film.
Volete sapere quanti film ho visto
in 17 anni?
Ben 795.
E meno male che non ho tenuto conto
delle serie tv.
Ho preso in considerazione
quante donne protagoniste ci fossero
in questo numero di film,
contando anche le controparti maschili.
Volete sapere quante ce n'erano?
Meno della metà.
E se vogliamo solo protagoniste femminili?
Il risultato è ancora peggio:
102 su 795.
Il dato è ovviamente condizionato
dal fatto che io di film
ne vedo abbastanza,
ma se prendessimo in considerazione
solo i film più famosi,
il dato potrebbe addirittura peggiorare.
Questi numeri mi hanno fatto capire
che nella maggior parte delle storie
per noi donne non c’è abbastanza spazio,
non ci viene data una voce
e non abbiamo ruoli importanti.
Già siamo poco rappresentate,
ma quando lo siamo
non abbiamo una rappresentazione
che ci renda abbastanza giustizia.
Avere una buona rappresentazione
è importante
perché ci aiuta ad abbattere
gli stereotipi
e ci fa avere più punti di vista
su qualcosa.
Per esempio, può anche far pensare
ad una ragazza di periferia come me
che può essere qualcosa di diverso
dai modelli che vede tutti i giorni.
È per questo motivo
che stamattina ho deciso di presentarvi
quali sono le rappresentazioni femminili
più ripetute
e perché queste siano un problema.
Partiamo da un tipo di storia
che tutti conosciamo: le fiabe.
In queste storie, spesso,
ci sono le principesse
che pensano ad una sola cosa:
a trovare il principe azzurro.
Come Ariel de “La sirenetta”
che passa tutta la sua vita,
a soli 16 anni rinuncia alla propria coda,
alla propria voce
per stare con un uomo visto di sfuggita.
E non solo.
Possiamo trovare storie
dove c’è una ragazza
che pensa solo e soltanto
a servire fedelmente un compagno
che la tratta pure male.
Per esempio, Misa Amane
del celebre anime “Death Note”.
Questo tipo di rappresentazione,
che purtroppo potete trovare
un po’ ovunque,
ci fa capire che le donne
dovrebbero pensare
solo alla propria vita sentimentale,
rigorosamente con un uomo.
Basta, nient'altro.
Ad ogni modo, andiamo oltre,
vediamo se la situazione migliora
con la rappresentazione
delle donne in carriera.
Prendiamo in considerazione
Miranda Presley
del film “Il diavolo veste Prada”.
Così come lei,
spesso troviamo delle donne
con alte posizioni lavorative,
ma ci viene fatto credere
che siano incomplete.
Vengono viste come infelici.
E perché?
Perché manca il loro uomo.
Sono da sole.
Ovvio che sono infelici.
Se ci pensate bene, invece,
quando vediamo degli uomini
con le loro stesse posizioni,
raramente si parla
della loro vita sentimentale.
Per non parlare delle donne forti
ma solo perché sono mascoline.
Ovviamente molte di loro,
come Mulan,
sono fantastiche
perché nei film salvano tutti quanti,
ma spesso sono frutto
di un sottile errore.
Quello di associare la forza
esclusivamente alla mascolinità.
Infatti è frequente trovare
queste donne mascoline,
contrapposte a donne
stereotipicamente femminili,
che sono viste come più deboli
o più antipatiche rispetto alle altre.
Per esempio, questo accade
nei primi episodi de “Il Trono di Spade”.
Da un lato c’è Arya Stark,
che ci appare
come un personaggio simpatico.
Ci viene presentata
come un personaggio positivo,
perché lei esce fuori dagli schemi,
si rifiuta di essere una lady,
vuole essere una guerriera.
Dall’altro lato c’è sua sorella Sansa,
lo stereotipo di lady perfetta,
ma ci viene presentata
come un personaggio negativo.
Un po’ più antipatica
rispetto alla sorella,
più debole.
E questo può accadere anche
con i personaggi maschili.
Attenzione!
Vi è mai capitato in un film,
in una serie tv,
di vedere
il classico personaggio effemminato
che ci viene presentato
come più debole rispetto agli altri?
Queste rappresentazioni riconfermano
la falsa credenza
che la femminilità
sia uguale alla debolezza.
Quello che dobbiamo capire è
che anche una persona
dai tratti e le attitudini
tipicamente femminili
può essere forte e indipendente.
L’ultimo modello
di cui vi voglio parlare
è uno dei peggiori.
E la fumettista statunitense
Kelly Sue DeConnick,
ha coniato un termine
che ce lo fa capire perfettamente:
“sexy lampada”.
L’autrice lo usa per farci capire
che molte volte i personaggi femminili
non hanno un reale impatto
sulla trama della storia
e che in questi casi,
se fossero sostituiti da una lampada sexy,
il senso della trama
non sarebbe sconvolto.
Ne è un esempio
il personaggio di Megan Fox
nella saga di Transformers.
Ma purtroppo ce ne sono tanti altri.
Questo accade
perché molti personaggi femminili
esistono soltanto
per attirare sguardi oggettivanti
di un pubblico prevalentemente maschile,
il cosiddetto “male gaze”.
Oppure,
possiamo trovare delle donne
che hanno effettivamente un’importanza
per la trama,
ma sono eccessivamente sessualizzate.
Come Vedova Nera
nei primi film
del Marvel Cinematic Universe.
Una rappresentazione di questo tipo
ci dice che la donna
ha valore solo per il suo aspetto,
non per il suo essere umana.
C’è chi pensa addirittura
che questo sia il motivo per il quale
le donne tendano in percentuale
ad avere meno posizioni nella politica,
meno posizioni di leadership,
perché la loro autorevolezza
viene sminuita.
Il fatto che nei giornali
le donne di potere vengano
spesso giudicate per i loro vestiti
per il loro trucco e per i loro capelli,
la dice lunga su questo.
E non solo.
Queste oggettivazioni non sono
una prerogativa solo delle storie,
ma le troviamo anche nelle pubblicità,
nei programmi televisivi,
nelle riviste.
Come questa pubblicità
di Dolce e Gabbana.
Per non citarne di peggiori.
Questi vari esempi ingabbiano le donne
in stereotipi di bellezza assurdi,
costringendole a essere sempre magre,
sempre sexy, interiorizzando il messaggio
che devono curare il loro aspetto,
non in base
a come vogliono essere loro stesse,
ma in base a quelli che sono i gusti
degli uomini,
portando questi ultimi
a svilirle,
a non vederle come degli esseri umani,
ma come degli oggetti.
Il sessismo nei media
è stato talmente normalizzato
che forse non ci facciamo più caso.
Eppure, abbiamo visto che le conseguenze
che può avere sono davvero pericolose.
Io personalmente non ci sto.
Perché queste rappresentazioni
sono un problema?
I modelli di cui vi ho parlato finora
sono un problema
spesso perché ci vengono proposti
solo questi.
In questo modo, i personaggi femminili
sono sempre uguali a loro stessi
e sono dei personaggi
che rinforzano stereotipi
della cultura patriarcale,
piuttosto che romperli.
Vanno ad assottigliare
la nostra prospettiva
nei confronti delle donne.
È per questo motivo
che noi dobbiamo andare contro corrente,
e dobbiamo incoraggiare
una rappresentazione
che sia tridimensionale.
Perché è importante avere dei modelli
da seguire,
complessi e sfaccettati.
Come facciamo a raggiungere
una rappresentazione paritaria?
Beh, ora voi penserete
che scrivere un buon personaggio femminile
sia un’impresa titanica.
Ma io vi dico
che basta una semplice cosa:
la libertà di scelta.
Un personaggio femminile
deve avere l’abilità
e la libertà di fare scelte
che cambino il corso degli eventi.
Deve avere un impatto sulla trama.
Deve agire in modo attivo nella storia.
Sono stanca di vedere donne
forti sia fisicamente che mentalmente,
che sono sempre in balìa
delle scelte degli altri
e non prendono mai in mano la situazione.
Alcuni di voi invece potrebbero pensare
che i problemi di cui vi ho parlato
sono ormai superati,
perché tanto ne abbiamo di esempi
di donne forti,
ma la verità è
che per poter pareggiare i conti
ce ne servono molti di più.
Bisogna incoraggiare però
non una sola versione di femminilità,
ma rappresentarli tutti
nella loro unicità e complessità.
Scrivere un buon personaggio femminile,
inoltre, non significa togliere qualcosa
ai personaggi maschili come molti credono,
non significa dover rappresentare
donne sempre vincenti e sempre potenti.
Infatti, molte protagoniste forti
non vengono apprezzate dalla massa
perché sono brave in tutto
e noi non riusciamo a empatizzare
con loro.
Dobbiamo quindi dimostrare
che questi personaggi
non sono forti perché non falliscono mai,
ma perché falliscono,
cadono, commettono errori,
ma dopo si rialzano, vanno avanti
e prendono in mano la situazione
come dovremmo fare anche noi.
Bisogna aggiungere,
non togliere.
Aggiungere quante più rappresentazioni
diverse e sfaccettate esistano.
E immaginate quanti personaggi originali
possiamo creare in questo modo.
Ovviamente non tutte le storie devono
essere educative ed edulcorate.
Ma ci sono alcuni esempi
che possono attecchire nella vita reale.
E magari,
possiamo insegnare ad una bambina
che il suo destino
non è aspettare passivamente
il principe azzurro col cavallo bianco
che la venga a salvare.
Ma che può prendere il
controllo della sua vita e agire da sola.
Grazie.
Complimenti, Mariapia Scilinguo!